in helping to mainstream libertarian
ideas I think Charles I think that's
Charles cokes legacy
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Daniel Schulman
he's a senior editor at Mother Jones and
he's the author of the explosive
provocative and absolutely must read
book sons of Wichita how the Koch
brothers became America's most powerful
and private dynasty damn thanks for
talking Q you know the big reveal in
your book or one of many and this is I
mean you look at the Koch brothers or
Koch Industries kind of rise to you know
super power within with an oil and gas
and a variety of other industries as
well as their political influence but a
big thing is that David and Charles Koch
and I'll point out a terms of full
disclosure David Koch sits on the board
of Reason Foundation that publishes
Reason TV but you point out that they
are libertarian not conservative explain
a little bit about what that means and
and how you know how did that hit you
when you when you started digging into
that well I think that's sort of an
interesting distinction but because
currently they really have a reputation
as republican power brokers or
kingmakers but you know part of the this
book was really looking at the roots of
their political thinking and ideology
and when you trace those back you see
that you know Charles Koch was you know
highly involved with the fledgling
libertarian movement of the late early
1960s and 70s you know at a time when
the movement could basically fit within
Murray Rothbard 's you know apartment
and what's interesting is that these
guys are considered conservatives but
they're really not social conservatives
in any sense of the word well I want to
talk a little bit about what are your
what's what are your sources for that or
how would you describe them I think some
of their own statements you know Charles
Koch has written about this stuff going
back to the 70s including in libertarian
review the magazine he owned in the late
70s up until I think maybe 1981 or
something like that there was an issue
on on libertarian strategy where he
wrote a really fascinating essay in
which he is sort of railing against the
businessmen of his time
for hypocrisy essentially that's because
they would look for you know they would
say oh well we're in favor of free
enterprise but they want either they
don't want to extend that to social
exactly they would they would rail
against welfare for the poor but at the
same time they would be seeking
corporate welfare they would be
partnering with government in order to
create regulations that would keep other
companies out oh you know and in the
book I mean you point out that these
guys you know David and Charles Koch are
the principals at Koch Industries they
are against all forms of subsidy that's
right they're they're really not you
know they're not saying oh except for my
business how does that change the
calculus of you know how they should how
you think they should be perceived by
you know the left by the right by
Americans in general well I think the
one misconception that people have about
these guys is that they are merely out
there to line their pockets and I think
if you look at their beliefs in sort of
a consistent framework you have to start
to see these guys outside the political
villain robber baron caricature crows
and and I mean just a you know I agree
with virtually all of what they talk
about there's obviously disagreements
but that this is they're not
opportunistic in any way shape or form
no but the one thing that I have an
op-ed in the Washington Post this
weekend which kind of discusses some of
the areas where there are misconceptions
about their politics including on social
issues obviously their anti-war they're
Pro civil liberties but then again you
don't really see them putting their
money's money where their mouths are so
much on these issues and I kind of
wondered if they were to do so if that
would a change their political image and
B if that would influence the Republican
Party insert well and this is
interesting because in the book you you
know again the cokes you know when
they're invoked as this kind of grand
abstraction you know the rasputin's of
the right or whatever you actually quote
a number of coke people in the book who
say hey you know what the GOP doesn't
trust us there are uncomfortable with us
you know is that because they're they
are actually can
assistant in saying we want small
government we don't want government
picking winners and losers and the
social issues in the narrow subset of
issues in which the Republicans and the
Koch brothers agree
I mean we're largely talking about
economic runs an interesting episode was
what that the cokes political advisors
the advisors sort of cringed at was
David Koch at the Republican National
Convention in Tampa in 2012 tells a
reporter that he's Pro gay marriage and
this is sort of highlight this is at the
time when the Republicans were in
training a plank in their platform
calling for a federal constitutional ban
on gay marriage so this was sort of
highlighting one of the areas where
they're out of sync with the Republican
Party and I think the cokes were cokes
people were trying to keep things sort
of simpatico here's a you know a
question I mean you write for a lefty
progressive magazine Mother Jones how do
you think if if it be you know if the
cokes came out and said yeah you know
what on social issues we don't think the
government should be involved would that
work
would that help them with the left or
would that not be meaningful I I do
think I mean at this point it's hard to
say because they've become such
political caricatures people on on the
left
you know sometimes instinctually hate
them in fact I had people after my book
came out sort of lambasted me for
treating them as quote too human so it's
unclear if things have kind of gotten
too far for people on left to actually
see that there's places of mutual
agreement with the coast how you know
here's a question one of the you know
one of the things that the Koch brothers
have been doing or Charles Koch in
particular has been hosting seminars
where he brings in wealthy people and
they create you know and they and they
raise money to push GOP candidates or
GOP issues and I guess it's not
specifically GOP it's that those that
tends to be the party that has
candidates that people want to do how
effective do you think they've been have
they been in these in these efforts to
kind of push a GOP ascendancy I think in
2012 the results were essentially a
colossal failure and they seem to be
quite did they seem to be painfully
aware of this and by day you're the
Coke's in their political their
political operation obby they had a lot
of high-profile donors including Foster
Friess who actually is a social
conservative right so isn't completely
in alignment of Charles and David Koch
who were quite turned off by both sort
of accountability issues about how the
money was spent and also about of course
the outcome right the one thing that's
in because so I mean going into the
election I mean all those all the signs
pointed to an incredibly vulnerable
Obama yep presidency I mean he's running
for a second term with terrible approval
ratings terrible economy you know
botched up foreign policy and yet the
you know the Republicans couldn't
deliver a winning candidate right and if
you it's the interesting thing is if you
talk to people on the conservative side
about the cokes political effort the one
thing they'll point out is that while
within Koch Industries they have this
rigid market-based management system
where they relentlessly measure anything
they didn't really see that same thing
taking place within the political
operation the one thing the Koch
brothers do do is that they really learn
from their mistakes so what you see
right now is kind of the overhaul of
their political operation I think 2014
is gonna be when it's a make-or-break
sort of situation I think you'll see
huge changes happen if the Republicans
don't take back the Senate for instance
what about at libertarian ideas how how
would you say you know and we're looking
at something that's basically 50 years
now Charles Koch has been affiliated
with a lot of groups including the
Institute for Humane studies which
started in the early 60s you know that
that kind of pushed libertarian ideas
and try and create a libertarian
infrastructure how would you measure
their success in that effort I think
they've been remarkably successful in
that in helping to mainstream
libertarian ideas I think Charles I
think that's Charles cokes legacy he
spent more than 50 years basically
trying to create and help to fund the
intellectual infrastructure for this
whether it's Institute for Humane
studies something like the Mercatus
Center or just one of the
hundreds of universities and academics
that he has funded I think he's been
hugely influential is that you know this
is something which it seems like on
either side of you know or any point on
the political spectrum people say oh
well that's bad you know because if you
fund somebody like in a friedrich hayek
or publishing friedrich hayek who's the
Nobel prize-winning economists work you
know then you're buying his brain power
somebody like Randy Barnett the
Georgetown Law professor who's a you
know a Titan of libertarian thought
who's gotten funding from a wide variety
of people is that just can't you know
when you know people on the right hated
when George Soros does and people on the
I mean do we have to get past that I
think so I mean because obviously you
know you you were got some you you it
helped but with literature that's what
that's what you studied right so I
personally don't see any problem with
the cokes using in Charles Koch using
his money to fund academic institutions
I know that there's been quite a bit of
controversy about this that places like
Florida State and elsewhere but that's
me it's like there's a separate issue
there's there was a there was an issue
about how the level of control that they
were seeking over this money and the
sort of vetting of professors and things
like that but in terms of just funding
fellowships and and that sort of thing I
mean it's given a lot of people
opportunities in higher education do you
think that we're entering a phase now
where you know there seems to be a kind
of revitalized progressive left not you
know not liberals but you know further
out on the left and kind of puncher and
more pugilistic I guess you know in
forward-looking as well as on the right
I mean it seems like and the broadly
construed right all of the energy is
coming from libertarian people it's not
coming from you know the Mike Huckabee's
of the world or the Rick Santorum's do
you think this you know the stage is
being set for the next kind of battle of
ideas between Liberty the libertarian
right and the progressive left and if so
you know can you handicap that good I
mean that's a very interesting question
and I think you could start to see that
happening absolutely in the US Congress
you see the rise
folks like Rand Paul who piloted
liberabit very staunchly libertarian guy
though he's you know under the
Republican party banner I'm not sure if
I could handicap how how things are
gonna shake out it is ya war well who
wins if the future is a fight between
say Elizabeth Warren and Rand Paul who
are you rooting for and who do you think
will win oh good your separate question
Wow
Elizabeth Warren hugely popular on the
Left right now great sort of populist
figure Rand Paul another guy who's been
energizing the right over a sort of a
range of issues and also has has gotten
kudos from folks on the on the left for
his stands against kind of drones and
his pro civil liberties it kind of NSA
reform I'm not sure I can say who wins
it it'll be a better world I hope if
that's who's making the arguments final
question how did you and I read in a
interesting kind of online chat you did
with Gawker you said that you're the the
thing that you look for most in a book
topic was or people interesting talk a
little bit about how you came into this
project and whether or not you know how
did your worldview kind of change from
going into it and coming out of it you
know ie in the 2010 and 2011 timeframe
of course the cokes are starting to
become get demonized and the first thing
I realized as I just looked into them a
little bit is of course there are four
Koch brothers not to UM you only hear
about Charles and David Koch those are
the Koch brothers and what interested me
more honestly more than their political
story was their family story there's a
long-running family drama that took
place I also thought it was a great
business story in the tale of Koch
Industries and you know one thing that I
think bothers Charles is the perception
that he was just some trust-fund kid and
kid which you disabuse ya know I mean
pretty well yeah I know I think I mean
it's it's clear that he he he took
a small mid-sized Midwestern oil and
cattle ranching empire and and really
turned it into something quite
remarkable that I don't think his dad
would recognize there's and there is a
kind of Shakespeare you know this might
be a little grand but there's a
Shakespearean dimension to you know the
father the patriarch Fred Koch bequeath
a company that's you know very wealthy
and well-off but then there's four sons
so that never goes well
right right and of course and you know
one interesting thing is that Charles
finds his letter has his dad writes
after his death and it says you know be
kind and generous to each other and this
also that this money that you're
inheriting could be a blessing or it
could be a curse and it turns out to be
both because this money is what ends up
fueling this major battle between the
brothers in place it is a you know this
is another reason why I think the book
is you know just really eminently
readable and provocative is that it's a
fantastic business history of a lot of
things going on in post-war America the
author is Daniel Shulman and the book is
sons of Wichita have the Koch brothers
became America's most powerful and
private dynasty thanks Dan thank you for
raising T V I'm Nick Gillespie